quand je dis ça rappelle tout de suite
le film
c'est exactement ça
on sait pas où on va on sait pas si
c'est dans une chatte sais pas si c'est
dans un parking
ces combats ensuite n'ont aucune
autorisation du tout
la jeunesse de ce documentaire c'est
youtube en fait ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que moi je suis passionné de
sports de combat depuis très longtemps
particulièrement de boxe anglaise et de
mma le mix est de marcher à l'arc qui
vient tout juste d'être légalisé en
france donc je regarde très souvent des
vidéos de combats de boxe ou du fc la
plus grosse organisation de combat de
mma dans le monde en parallèle de sa
faut aussi savoir que ça fait des années
que des vidéos de street fight ou de
combats de rue non autorisées sont
diffusées sur youtube que ce soit des
groupes de 40 cas qu'ils s'affrontent au
fin fond de la russie ou d un contre un
dans des arrière cours ou des jardins
aux états unis je m'étais toujours dit
que j'essayerai de faire une série
documentaire sur ces différents univers
de combats qu'ils soient légaux ou non
et en fait c'est en fin d'année dernière
que j'ai découvert le chaos ts le king
of the street un fight club underground
en suède ultra populaires sur les
réseaux sociaux et c'est d'eux dont je
vais vous parler dans cette vidéo
il organise des combats à mains nues où
il n'ya pas de règles pas de ronde et où
tous les coups sont permis ces failles
peuvent se dérouler dans plein
d'endroits différents que ce soit en
forêt dans des parkings ou des hangars
et la plupart du temps c'est sur du
béton la plupart des gars qui viennent
combattre au chaos ts sont des hooligans
issus du football j'ai aussi croisé des
combattants professionnels des amateurs
des néo nazis et des anti fasciste qui
viennent régler leurs comptes dans la
cage mais aussi des gars lambda qui
n'ont rien à voir avec tout ça et qui
veulent vivre une expérience de combat
sans règles et après que ce soit au
niveau des combattants ou des
spectateurs il y avait tous les milieux
professionnels toutes les cultures
toutes les nationalités et cela posait
pas de problème la première fois qu'on
regarde des images des combats du chaos
thèse ça peut paraître hyper choquant
mais en réalité il ya plein
d'organisation légal de combat à mains
nues on appelle ça le berck nuckle et on
a une très grosse aux états unis et y en
a aussi en angleterre et dans les pays
de l'est
voilà c'est juste qu'on n'a pas vraiment
l'habitude en france mais ces combats
existe un peu partout dans le monde ils
sont accessibles sur internet pour
pénétrer à l'intérieur de ce fight club
en fait ça m'a pris plusieurs mois dans
un premier temps j'ai trouvé comment
contacter les organisateurs du chaos ts
sur l'application de messagerie
télégramme j'aurais envoyé plein de
messages pendant des semaines et ils ne
m'ont jamais répondu et après je me suis
posé la question de savoir est ce qu'il
ya des français qui vont combattre là
bas et le premier gars que j'ai trouvée
via le compte facebook du king of the
streets c'était un mec qui se faisait
appeler french speaking je me suis dit
qu'il était sûrement français et j'ai
commencé à le chercher je les trouvais
sur instagram et je lui ai envoyé un
message il m'a répondu assez rapidement
et on a fini par se rencontrer avec son
coach quelques semaines plus tard
réjouis toi
de la chance que tu as tu vas combat
un bon mètre qu'on connaît bien il a dit
quoi il a dit
préparer un combat c'est comme un enfant
qui attend noël
les jours du combat tu dois être heureux
pas facile
je redis que je voulais filmer leurs
entraînements je voulais filmer le
déplacement et pouvoir aller à
l'intérieur du fait de club parce que ça
n'ait pas été fait auparavant et je
voulais le voir de mes propres yeux
avant d'en faire un documentaire de
l'extérieur pour moi c'était hyper
important il n'y avait pas de
documentaire si je pouvais pas y aller
bref on a discuté pendant plusieurs
semaines et au début ce n'était pas
possible le coach k est temps que vous
verrez dans le film et 20 20 me disais
que l'organisateur de ces combats il
n'aime pas les journalistes
il veut pas que des gens viennent donc
on s'est dit que la première fois qu'on
partait ensemble en suède il fallait que
j'y aille en tant qu'assistant du coach
j'y suis allé une première fois en
février et j'ai pas vraiment filmé par
contre j'ai pu rencontrer les
organisateurs leur part les gens mais
pas tout de suite dit qui j'étais mais
en gros je leur disais que je faisais
des films et c'est que j'étais passionné
de sports de combat qui me connaissaient
bien ils l'ont bien vu parce que j'avais
déjà regardé la majorité de leurs vidéos
sur youtube et je connaissais la plupart
de leurs combattants par leur nom et
leur palmarès au chaos tf donc il savait
que je m'intéressais vraiment à eux au
bout de quelques semaines avec l'aide du
coach on a réussi à les convaincre de me
laisser venir filmer et la deuxième fois
que j'y suis allé j'ai eu carte blanche
oui
[Musique]
elle aimait ça
nous
attends je vais
c'est marrant
je pense que c'est pour les cheveux
alors voir
il y en avait partout et on se doit
en gros il ya un mec qui vient de
chercher à l'hôtel tu montes dans une
voiture et tu ne sais pas où tu vas tu
arrives dans un endroit lambda mois de
reprise ça a été dans un hangar
différent à chaque fois et tu rentres
dans un univers très dark ta que des
gars cagoulés tatoué hyperbare à quai
bref il ya énormément de testostérone
ensuite pendant quelques heures avant
que l'événement commence les gens
discutent un peu ça s'échauffe il ya
vraiment une ambiance très particulière
une fois que l'événement commence ça va
très très vite en général il ya une
dizaine de combats et ils durent pas
très longtemps c'est normal parce que si
tu prends une droite un câble accroché
où un gros uppercut à mains nues à
pleine balle dans la tête en général t k
o
évidemment ces combats sont hyper
impressionnant et le fait que ce soit
sur du béton a clairement l'intégrité
physique des combattants elle est
beaucoup plus en danger que si c'était
sur un tatami ou dans une organisation
légale et même s'il ya des médications
place des infirmiers pour faire des
points de futurs ou autres s'il ya le
moindre problème vu que ce sont des
combats non autorisée il n'ya pas
d'ambulance donc il faut amener les
blessés à l'hôpital en voiture la
première fois où j'y suis allé j'ai dû
amener un combattant à l'hôpital avec
son coach parce qu'ils venaient de
prendre un énorme cadeau donc faut
vraiment que les gars qui vont dans
cette cage sache impérativement à quoi
ils s'exposent c'est pas un jeu et c'est
extrêmement dangereux une des premières
questions que je me suis posée c'est est
ce que ces mecs sont payés pour faire ça
et la réponse est oui et non déjà ça
dépend du niveau du combattant pour les
novices qui n'ont jamais combattu que ce
soit en amateur ou en professionnel
évidemment qu'ils n'ont pas la même
prime que les combattants le pro je sais
qu'en général pour un premier combat la
victoire c'est quelques centaines
d'euros genre 400 et c'est vraiment pas
énorme par rapport aux risques que tu
prends quand tu pénètres dans cette cage
et s'ils perdent ils ne gagnent rien
donc en vrai la plupart des gars qui
vont là bas c'est vraiment beaucoup plus
pour l'expérience que pour la
potentielle prime qui pourrait gagner
prospect n'ont
pas sali
monaco
ce tournage n'a pas été facile parce qu'
il fallait à la fois que les mecs sur
place là bas me donne les autorisations
il fallait aussi que combattant et le
coach que j'ai suivi accepte ma caméra
et que je rentre dans leur intimité
[Musique]
welcome in de cela quand tu te soumets
donc là rien ce sont 900 kg 109 kg vers
17 ans partira d'ici le temps qui n'est
pas 100 kg
je suis avec toi cinq minutes chrono
c'est parti
[Musique]
je tiens encore
passer les moments de ce qu'on vient de
cuisson pour par 5 kg hamon avait eu
leurs
ancêtres à ce rythme là ok c'est moi
qu'il faut ça va jouer quatre sessions
sont là
on n'allait pas si les médecins devaient
[Musique]
ainsi toigo claude jacquot 6 1 6 3
[Applaudissements]
comme j'ai dit c'était la cession la
plus dure moi je pense que ce qui m'a le
plus marqué c'est de voir à quel point
tous ces mecs là était passionné de
combat de voir à quel point il aime se
battre mais malgré la défaite y en a
beaucoup qui reviennent et après les
avoir filmé je peux comprendre qu'on
puisse trouver ça complètement
inconscient et foot surtout quand on
n'est pas attirée par les combats et
qu'on n'a jamais vécu une expérience de
ce type mais je peux aussi comprendre
pourquoi on a envie d'aller dans cette
cage pêche veut pas trop vous spoiler
tout ce que j'ai vu dans ce fight club
complètement dingue je préfère vous
alliez sur brut x.com pour voir ce
documentaire de 52 minutes qui va vous
plonger en immersion dans cet univers
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a pu
foncer voir le documentaire sur brit x
venez m'en parlait en commentaire j'ai
hâte de lire bon retour parce que chez
moi ça a suscité beaucoup
d'interrogations j'en ai parlé pendant
des mois avec mes potes qui sont
combattants pro avec mon entourage avec
brut et c est ça a suscité beaucoup de
débats donc j'ai hâte de vous lire mais
me mettre vos retours et on en débat
tous ensemble donc voilà foncez vous
abonner faites moi un max de retour et a
très vite